on refait un un détour par Kiev vous
l'avez vu à l'instant sur notre antenne
cette rencontre voilà entre les
présidents américains et ukrainiens ont
écouté pour le devenir
qui nous attend sera compliqué
il y aura peut-être des difficultés ou
pas nous ne le savons pas
mais nous avancerons ensemble avec nos
partenaires cet hiver nous vous
remercions en l'honneur de en au nom de
notre population votre soutien financier
et crucial
c'est un plaisir de vous voir et de voir
votre équipe c'est ma quatrième visite
en
Ukraine depuis l'agression russe
en 2022
et je suis toujours frappé par le
courage la force et la résilience du
peuple des soldats ukrainiens
et aussi des dirigeants Ukrainiens
nous sommes résolus
a continué à avancer à vos côtés
le président Biden m'a demandé de venir
ici pour réaffirmer notre soutien
pour faire en sorte que
nos efforts soit au maximum pour faire
face aux tâches
qui se présentent actuellement mais
aussi les tâches à plus long terme de
reconstruire l'Ukraine et pour dissuader
toute éventuel agression future
et nous vous aiderons à renforcer votre
démocratie et reconstruire votre pays
nous voyons qu'il y a des avancées
importantes qui ont été réalisées
dans le cas de la contrefensive
les États-Unis ont été heureux de
participer aux événements ce matin avec
la première dame qui a réalisé un
travail extraordinaire
et nous sommes heureux d'avoir pu
participer de pouvoir aider
un message d'humidité très important
était transmis
le travail de la première dame pour
faire face à la situation actuelle a été
remarquable